and I know that we've got just ten days  to make sure that magic ingredient and  that recovering economy keeps delivering  the jobs we want keeps delivering the  growth we need keeps delivering for the  public services we want to provide and  if you think I'm going to roll over in  the next ten days and let ed miliband  and Alex Salmond rack that you've got  another thing coming we got a fight on  our hands looking to win that fight you  know what they call you they say  business is a predator this is not some  Arnold Schwarzenegger movie this is what  we're staring down the barrel off in 10  days time if we don't get out there and  fight for jobs and fight for enterprise  and fight for our economy and that's  what we're gonna do